An unknown alliance, a secret eff you, and
a damning hint towards the future?
There’s secrets stitched into these sci-fi
threads!
So which one plays homage to detectives and
suffragettes?
Wil Wheaton's Wesley Crusher made his Star
Trek debut in an episode of The Next Generation
in 1987.
The son of Dr. Beverly Crusher, he's long
been one of the fandom's most divisive characters.
Some found him annoying.
Others found his super-genius skills preposterous.
And the rest just didn't like the idea of
a teenager on the bridge of the Enterprise.
Nevertheless, Crusher received the provisional
rank of Acting Ensign in the episode "Where
No One Has Gone Before" along with his own
special uniform.
Acting Ensign Wesley Crusher's costume – an
awkward gray-toned turtleneck with a rainbow
stripe that wraps around the shoulders – set
him apart from the rest of the crew.
It also held a secret message.
The colorful stripe across his chest is made
up of all three divisional colors worn by
the rest of the crew.
Red represents the command division, yellow
is for security and operations, and blue is
for science and medical.
Crusher wears all three to denote that, as
a provisional officer, he hasn't yet chosen
a division.
Jodi Whittaker Thirteenth Doctor on Doctor
Who faced sexist backlash following her casting,
but few found fault with her colorful, offbeat
outfit.
Whittaker first appeared in a blue shirt with
a rainbow stripe, a long gray coat, and suspenders
holding up a pair of blue trousers, which
gave the Thirteenth Doctor the right mix of
style and quirkiness.
But while fans noticed subtle homages to the
past — the Fourth Doctor's colorful stripes,
the Eleventh Doctor's bow ties, and the high-waisted
pants of the Second Doctor — there's more.
For example, the blue and gray represent the
sky and space.
In a behind-the-scenes featurette, Whittaker
pointed to her earrings, saying,
"And then there's a whole journey of stars
and hands in the earring.
The chain is the journey, and the rose gold
hand is humanity."
Costume designer Ray Holman added a violet
lining to her coat sleeves because it was
one of the colors of the suffragettes, the
activists who fought for women's votes in
the United Kingdom.
For Whittaker, it was important that her costume
not be overly feminine or masculine.
She explained,
"The main journey of it came from a photograph
that I found of a woman in trousers, braces,
and a t-shirt walking with purpose."
Whittaker loved its intrigue and timelessness,
and the Thirteenth Doctor's style was born.
A genre-breaking superhero movie that shattered
long-held Hollywood perceptions, Black Panther
saw the late Chadwick Boseman lead the people
of Wakanda to glory.
Wakanda is home to a rare element called Vibranium,
which allows the country to develop futuristic
technology while still honoring the people's
culture and traditions.
Costume designer Ruth E. Carter created many
of the futuristic outfits seen in the film
to pay homage to Africa's past.
Inspired by the style called Afrofuturism,
Carter created some 700 unique costumes for
the movie, including ceremonial dress and
the warrior armor worn by the likes of Okoye.
"We crafted a costume that really did represent
all the areas of Africa."
For example, Carter incorporated beadwork
from the Turkana tribe and leather skirts
wrapped the way the women of the Himba tribe
dress.
In an interview with NPR, she explained,
"I really wanted this to have a feeling that,
if you were an aspiring Dora Milaje – if
you were training and you were granted the
position to be a member, that you would be
presented with this honor and this beautiful
uniform."
"It's a great honor for someone to be a Dora
Milaje.
They also wear neck rings and arm rings that
are from South Africa."
For the 2022 sequel, Wakanda Forever, Carter
designed another 2,000 outfits, including
the Midnight Angel armor worn by Okoye.
Using the original comic book art as a starting
point, real African designs were added.
She told Entertainment Weekly,
"We landed on a mask style that's very much
like the masks of Benin or South Africa, where
you see this slanted eye with a round shape."
The Back to the Future trilogy didn't require
much elaborate costuming.
The first and third films are set in the past,
but 1989's Back to the Future Part II plays
out in the far-off future of 2015.
Oddly enough, though, it's not the slick,
futuristic fashion worn by Marty McFly, or
the cyber-punk costumes of Biff Tannen and
his cronies that hide some hidden meaning.
Instead, it's the more ordinary attire of
scientist Doc Brown.
Throughout the film, Brown wears a bright,
loosely fitted button-down shirt.
But look closely and you'll see the shirt
doesn't feature the Hawaiian flowers you might
expect, but a repeating pattern depicting
a steam locomotive.
It's no coincidence, of course, that in the
third and final film in the series, Marty
and Doc Brown hijack just such a train to
carry them back to the future.
Later, Brown even uses a locomotive as a time
machine, and here it was, a year earlier,
being foreshadowed in his shirt.
But that's not all.
Pay close attention to the train hijacking
scene in Back to the Future Part III and you'll
see that Doc uses the same shirt — torn
up — as his face covering while playing
a gun-toting bandit.
A mind-bending sci-fi journey through the
Wild West — at least at first — Westworld
is peppered with clues for the audience.
Viewers pore over every scene hunting for
details that may hold some significance.
And the cast's elaborate costumes are always
a good place to start.
"The architecture guided the costumes, so
there's a lack of detail to most of our costumes
that's intentional."
While costume designer Shay Cunliffe insists
that many of the clothing decisions weren't
as deliberate as some fans believe, they were
absolutely influenced by the story's deeper themes.
But there was at least one choice that hid
a deeper meaning.
In Season 3, when Dolores returns, the many
blue outfits are a nod to the iconic blue
dress she wore inside the park in the first
two seasons.
Also, when Clementine returns — now in the
outside world — her post-modern dress matches
her flowing gown from inside the Westworld
park.
In an interview with Insider, Cunliffe referred
to such callbacks as part of a "theme-song
of color" that ran throughout the series.
Based on the seminal novel by Margaret Atwood,
The Handmaid's Tale takes place in a grim
near future in which the United States has
become an authoritarian society.
Women are a subjugated lower class in bland
robes and bonnet-like head coverings that
are color coded based on their role in society.
Handmaids wear blood red.
Wives wear royal blue.
Domestic workers wear green, and so on.
The outfits are designed to show the women's
complete lack of power.
Costume designer Ane Crabtree told Vanity
Fair,
"It was kind of twisted to think about how
I would hinder women — their body shape,
and also their movement and their freedom
with the clothing.
I had to do it to make it realistic, but also
to help the actors."
"You feel blinkered.
Completely blinkered"
She went on to explain that she took a psychological
approach to the color-coded system, saying,
"There's less and less power as you go down
the color spectrum, except with the color
red — that is by design from the book."
Her job was to create outfits designed by
oppressors, though she admitted she hid a
couple of things in the designs that were
meant to be a "f— you" to the men keeping
these women down.
She confessed,
"I did an inverted female vagina in the design
of the Aunt's collars.
If you look subtly, you'll see that."
It's no coincidence that the costumes worn
by the authoritarian Terran Federation in
Starship Troopers recall those worn by high-ranking
Nazi officers during World War II.
Over the years, director Paul Verhoeven has
spoken about how the film, which is based
on the Robert A. Heinlein novel of the same
name, is a satire of military dictatorships
like the Third Reich.
For example, Carl Jenkins, played by a young
Neil Patrick Harris, wears a uniform that
starkly invokes the Gestapo, Adolf Hitler's
secret police.
Rather than glorifying authoritarianism as
many critics wrongly assumed upon the film's
release, the uniforms were meant to be a subtle
takedown of the frightening ways authoritarian
regimes justify their brutality.
Verhoeven told Entertainment Weekly,
"What I tried to do is use subversive imagery
to make a point about society.
I tried to seduce the audience to join [the
movie's] society, but then ask, 'What are
you really joining up for?"'
1999's The Matrix may be one of the most analyzed
sci-fi films ever made.
From the film's trans allegory to its prescient
look at a future ruled by data and consumerism,
every detail of the film has been pored over
since its release.
And the costume of arguably the film's most
important character, the Oracle, hasn't escaped notice.
Depicted as an older, motherly woman, the
Oracle can see Neo's future.
"You're the Oracle?"
"Bingo."
She appears in an ordinary suburban kitchen
dressed in a green blouse and an orange apron,
but this simple costume actually mirrors the
work of renaissance master Michelangelo.
The outfit recalls the Delphic Sibyl, who
appears in Michelangelo's most celebrated
work, the ceiling of the Sistine Chapel.
The Delphic Sibyl is a seer, one of the most
powerful prophets in the ancient world.
According to legend, she even predicted the
Trojan War.
Ridley Scott's Blade Runner, based on Phillip
K. Dick's novel, Do Androids Dream of Electric
Sheep?, is a cyberpunk sci-fi movie about
a government agent who hunts down rogue androids.
Everything from the dialogue and the sets
to the use of color and lighting is meant
to pay homage to old detective movies, including
Rick Deckard's look, which is influenced by
movies of that era.
In a chat with AnOther magazine, costume designer
Michael Kaplan explained,
"We definitely felt that Blade Runner was
of that film noir genre, and we looked back
to the films of the 1940s for inspiration.
Deckard was as much a Gumshoe as [The Maltese
Falcon's] Sam Spade."
In fact, Deckard's costume is an obvious tip
of the cap to the iconic detective, a sort
of futuristic Spade.
The 2017 sequel, Blade Runner 2049, took a
different route.
It's set 30 years later and the world is an
even worse place, so the wardrobe had to reflect that.
The clothing in the second film is tougher,
more durable, bulkier, and uglier.
"The fashion is like very expressive but linked
with surviving.
And how they will incorporate survival gears
in those clothes and making them like fashion statements."
Designer Renée April told IndieWire,
"I didn't want costumes with [lots of] zippers
and plastic.
So my job was to make the characters believable."
2021's Dune is a sweeping outer space saga
where rival houses battle for control of a
vast interstellar empire.
Based on the Frank Herbert novel of the same
name, Dune calls for futuristic battle suits
and outfits that can withstand the environments
on harsh alien worlds, but also formal attire
for the powerful House Atreides.
The architecture of the film is drawn from
a school of design called brutalism, and some
of the outfits have a similar origin.
"For me, I wanted the costume design to feel
like a historical movie.
To move away from fantasy."
In a 2021 interview with The Hollywood Reporter,
costume designer Jacqueline West discussed
the source of inspiration, saying,
"You want it simple, stripped-down, utilitarian.
I approached nearly all of the costumes that
way.
I never wanted anything to look over-reaching,
or overdone and baroque in any way."
West took cues from the Romanov family, the
last dynasty to rule Russia before the revolution,
explaining,
"I thought their costumes were quite elegant
yet simple."
Why the Romanovs, though?
It's quite simple.
As West explained to The Hollywood Reporter,
"I thought they were a doomed family, just
like the House of Atreides, where everything
was about to be taken away from them.
I thought there would be some symbolism for
the audience to see and feel that.
Maybe they would make that connection, even
subliminally."